let's talk about this first really
creepy story
it's it's a it's a really really creepy
story because we have a bunch of
different outlets that have reported
this
did agents raid the home of a wrong
woman over january 6th riot
maybe that's the creepiest thing about
the maybe
this story from the hour isn't the only
outlet that said maybe they did
a bunch of other outlets did i think
even the ap was like they might have
but if you go to anchorage daily news
apparently one of the only outs that
actually looked into this story
they have a photograph of the woman
during during the january 6 rally in
which trump was speaking in dc
and a photo of the woman the fbi was
actually looking for here's a funny
thing okay
so maybe they're of similar age and
their hair is kind of similar
the woman whose home was raided as they
were looking for nancy pelosi's laptop
was wearing a gray scarf and i guess
some kind of like low cut or v or open
neck shirt
and the woman they're actually looking
for has big hoop earrings
and is not wearing a gray scarf and has
some kind of i don't know weird
flower pattern shirt clearly not the
same person
so how is it that the fbi hasn't been
able to figure out who stole the laptop
they haven't been able to figure out who
was planting pipe bombs what are they
doing
i guess tracking down bumbling dotards
who walked in confused
so here's where it gets really crazy
apparently in this court filing
they mentioned that it was an alaska
airlines employee
who got into an altercation with these
people because they weren't wearing
masks they got banned
and then i guess this is where it gets
weird someone from alaska airlines
looked up this woman's social media
account
saw a post a few days later about
being in dc on january 6 not in the
capitol mind you
just not in the capitol building just
there because trump was giving
was was rallying then called the fbi and
tipped them off
and that was grounds for the fbi to go
to homer alaska
and break this woman's door in and then
go and search for a laptop
all right did they find it of course
they didn't because this was the wrong
woman and now all these these
these uh outlets are saying like maybe
it was the wrong woman okay you know
what fine let's play the maybe game
maybe this woman shows up in dc to hear
trump speak
and then everybody decides to go into
the capital so she takes off her jacket
puts on a takes off her scarf throws it
away puts on a totally different shirt
attaches new earrings all within the
span of
you know a couple hours i guess while
people are outside marching around
i just find the whole thing just
ridiculous and
i don't know man it makes me a bit
pessimistic because it feels like the
doj at this point has become completely
politicized and i'll tell you what this
is going to sound totally unrelated but
it really freaked me out
we grilled today we made burgers they
were delicious
they were local farm burgers apparently
the local farms were telling us
that or so we were told by local farmers
the fda's put restrictions on their
ability to sell beef until recently
and i'm like i didn't hear that how come
that's not in the news how come how come
these stories aren't in the news
it really does feel like a whole bunch
of weird and wacky stuff
is happening right you've got something
going on with this this arizona
audit of the election the fbi flying to
some women's home in alaska desperate to
find a laptop they can't figure out
where it is
we've got weird stuff with a dollar i
don't know man it all seems unrelated
but it's all to me
it's indicative of like a rot in the
foundation of the system when you say
weird things with the dollar like it's
terrifying explosive inflation
that's like devastating the economy and
that's not being talked about
so i'm not overly shocked that other
weird
stuff is going on too it just feels like
it's breaking apart dude
uh let's ring the alarms the fbi can
kick your door down if they think you're
someone
even if you just kind of look like
somebody is that was that where we're at
i'm not surprised
that they could do this they can get a
warrant from a judge and then go do it
it's just it's i i'm like
i'm just at this point we're watching
all this news every day i mean we were
sitting here before we pulled up the
story and i'm just like i don't even
care
i don't even i don't i don't even know
what's going on anymore dude it's like i
can tell you a million and one things
but i can tell you one thing is that
antifa goes and throws rocks through
windows and bashes skulls
whatever happened to that that old man
in in kenosha got his head bashed in by
samantha
nobody get arrested for that nothing
happened oh but some lady
gets her it's a door kicked i i i see
that i see chauvin i see these these
these cases
i see the juror lying and i'm just like
who has confidence in the us government
at this point
aspects of it what about what are you
gonna say i mean how do you decide what
to pay attention to do you feel like
you're feeding
like because we are engineering
you know consciousness by what we're
covering what we're talking about
and so but you like you need to go
towards the rot
but you kind of need to balance that out
i mean
i'm reading the general news right
so when i when i look at news stories
i'm looking at like all of these
different stories and i'm
ignoring a lot of things i think i you
know things i don't care about so
i don't know stories about celebrity
gossip and
a lot of stories about like some
instagram model where a bikini to the
beach
and then it's like front page news and a
bunch of outlets yeah it gets clicks i
get it
when it comes to cultural issues
political issues
i'm trying to see what is going on and
and what matters most and what's having
a big impact
but admittedly i'm only able to look at
what journalists are for the most part
already doing now we are going to be
launching a newsroom soon we'll have a
lot of
we'll have some we'll start we're going
to start doing our own original
reporting but that's why i was saying
it's like
i brought up the beef thing it's
seemingly unrelated
but i think it's a really good example
of people not realizing that
i think we're being distracted by a lot
of this stuff and what i mean is
this fbi thing is scary it's creepy the
the
an alaska airlines employee sending in a
tip to the fbi about a woman because of
a mask
altercation that's just like really
creepy like stuff
like what was she doing pulling up this
woman's instagram because she was mad at
her or some something like that
it's weird and then the fbi goes and
goes to her house and kicks the door and
looking for nancy pelosi's laptop
this is like out of a bad action movie
so this is this this is some of the
biggest news you hear the mainstream
media talking about what's going on with
january 6th oh they rated this woman's
home
and it was like 1984 level snitch on
your neighbor's stuff which is just
very strange but then i hear this i i
hear this today when we're like
we're going we're like let's grab
burgers and we'll we'll grill and have
some burgers they were delicious by the
way
local beef and then apparently the
farmers are like oh yeah we weren't
allowed to uh to actually sell any of
this for a while the fda wouldn't let us
and i'm like what yeah it's like raw
milk i mean
just no but it's something to do with
the lockdowns sometimes it was the
lockdowns it was coveted
and so what i'm saying is we do have
these really creepy weirdo stories
in the mainstream media and it's really
frustrating actually when you hear like
the juror and the chauvin trial
not only did he lie about the protest he
lied about his shirt he's wearing the
the the george floyd shirt
and he's like i remember wearing that
and there's a video of him wearing it
from a different time
from like months earlier or like months
later or something like that and so
you see we see all this stuff and that's
like
where the focus is when it comes to
politics but we're not paying attention
to is regulatory stuff
what's going on have you noticed a huge
shortage of a ton of different goods
first of all lumber's already expensive
steel's expensive food is skyrocketing
but it's not just that
yeah bacon's going going up we couldn't
find it you couldn't find bacon yeah we
went to costco the other day we couldn't
find any bacon and we're like what's
going
on okay we're in trouble things get real
is when you can't find the stuff yeah
i'll tell you what i did i ordered a
bunch of bacon i put in our deep freezer
smart
yeah because you know when the
apocalypse comes should they say in the
in the in the land of a broken economy
the man with bacon is king i want a man
i could see a pig here
to be honest a pig
they're like dogs kind of ian will get
way too attached
yeah he'd be my best friend yeah just
get a pig and don't kill it
i think he'll just keep it around it'll
be good no it's just it's just it's it's
weird stuff that people aren't paying
attention to
uh i tried buying cat food couldn't do
it well why
it took like like a month and a half two
months to get cat food wow yeah so
uh we ended up getting this cat food
that bucko doesn't like huh
this reminds me of if this if we were
living on the titanic
and this is the part of the movie where
they're like uh this is when everyone
should be getting on live posts but we
don't have enough lifeboats so don't
freak everybody out cause there'll be a
mad dash and people will smash and kill
you so they're not telling us to get on
the lifeboats i've got huge news
oh what do you guys remember when
crowder sent me that gun yeah
okay so i'm gonna tell everybody the
story of what happened with with with
crowder send me this gun
actually yeah uh let me let me let me
let me let me
i'll get into the story but let me just
say a few things but i got too excited
there
and i'll just say i got to lead into it
better than that instead of just going
like i was good though
i'm really excited okay hold on hold on
ian's right uh so i got concerned about
the riots
in in you know when we were in the
philly area because
it's this is the craziest thing about
new jersey i've talked about it before
it's a duty to retreat
even from your own home like seriously
if you are in your house in new jersey
they say it's a partial castle doctrine
state and so i'm like okay what does
that mean
it means if someone breaks into your
home and you can escape
you have to leave your house and i'm
like but go go where
and it's only if it's completely safe
and so then you got to argue to a court
why
it was like complete it was a totally
safe or
i'm sorry it has to be like in order to
be totally
safe you have to leave if there's some
risk to you by doing it then they could
argue
that you should have stayed in your home
or whatever but if you can safely leave
your home you have to
so i'm like i don't want to be in this
stuff i remember going to the stores and
seeing all the shortages and everything
and then thinking like man should we
be preppers because it's funny people
like to make fun of the preppers but the
preppers don't care
i don't know if you guys have seen like
prepper videos recently
yeah they don't they don't care what the
media says about them they're just like
whatever occur
you know i've got i got a bunch of
toilet paper while you guys are fighting
over it they're living a great life
growing food
i mean why and preparing growing food
living on farms and i don't know if they
think the world's going to end tomorrow
but
hey man the dollar is uh is is is
in pretty bad shape but let me let me so
let me let me tell you now let me let me
now that i've built the suspense up a
little bit enough to talk about this
this this crowder thing
i got a big update on that gun that
crowder was supposed to send me so this
is like over a year ago
i think it was over a year ago yeah it
was i went on louder crowder
and i don't think i had a gun at this
point i was like doing the paperwork to
get one
and so steven was like
tim buddy we're getting you a gun and
he's like we're going to send you the
sig m400
you know it's the cadillac of guns and
i'm like awesome dude thank you so much
and then everybody wanted to know what
happened to it and just no one ever
heard
about i've never talked about it i've
never showed us no instagram photos just
just never happened well here's what
happened there apparently was only
one gun shop in new jersey that could do
the modifications to make it new jersey
legal because new jersey is a horrible
state for firearms
and so crowder's a team ended up sending
it to the one shop that could take it
the only problem it was about 70 miles
away from where we were
and that would mean driving for about an
hour and a half in in
in the middle of a day where i'm working
mornings and nights and on weekends and
i couldn't do it
i'd have to drive up there fill out the
next background check form
drive back home wait three to five days
because i was on a delay list
then drive back and do it again i'm like
i can't do that like i got a company to
run i got shows to do
there's no point in the day which i
could leave and go do this
so i told crowder i was like look it got
sent to a
you know a shop that's too far away from
me i can't go get it well i got a phone
call today
and this shop calls me and they're like
it's been uh
you know we're cleaning out the storage
room it's been about a year and
we found uh this this gun and it's for
you
that i got i got a voicemail i didn't i
didn't listen to it until afterwards but
i got the
missed call and i call them they're like
yeah you know we're cleaning up the shop
and we realized we had this gun sitting
here for almost a year
do you still want it and i was like wow
i do
want it can you send it to my ffl and
they were like
sure thing so i'm finally getting oh
nice
yeah so i i checked the voicemail and
there was
it was like this woman and she was like
if it's been sitting here for a year and
we're supposed to charge you five bucks
a day for all that's been sitting here
but
you know whatever if you don't want it
then we're gonna start charging you now
but calls back and i was like sure and i
called him back
and the problem was when we were in new
jersey they had to do a bunch of
modifications to it
and i was like i can't pick this up and
then you know
i guess they theoretically could have
modified it or then shipped it out
whatever but
it just just fell off so it's gonna it's
gonna be surprising they didn't say we
can't ship it
for some stupid reason no they were
totally cool yeah yeah shout out they
were they were really cool and they're
like nah we got you man don't worry
about it
and so i guess the issue was when we
were when we were there
it needed to be modified for new jersey
which was going to cost money
and then but now now we're not now we're
essentially
between like maryland and west virginia
and so
it's what was the modification oh dude
new jersey's got like crazy rules about
what you can or can't have on a gun it's
just so arbitrary
it's like they have to make it so that
when you when you pull the trigger
a flag comes out with it's red and says
bang on it
otherwise it's not legal yeah it's the
only legal way to get a gun that makes
more sense oh jersey
yeah yeah so we're getting it and uh
anyway i got all excited because uh
unmodified
fully yeah fully on my phone it's gonna
be it's gonna be like
as it as the sega m400 comes looking
forward to seeing this thing i've never
even seen a picture of it
i yeah supposedly it's a cool gun looks
like a gun
i think you know it was supposed to be
my first i guess and that's going to be
like my 30th
so i i want i want to circle back as jen
sackey would say
to uh this this metaphor earlier i was
talking about about us
looking for lifeboats like how the
government's kind of distracting us or
how we're being distracted by the media
when it's time to get in the lifeboats
yes we're being distracted but i want to
clarify my point i don't i'm not
necessarily
uh saying it was intentionally
misleading us yeah maybe not maybe
i think everybody is hyper focused on
the same thing and we're all staring off
to our left and
meanwhile on the right like there's a
volcano erupting this is
i have so many so many things to say
about i want to read this nichi quote
this is um when nietzsche was talking
about the abyss he said beware that when
fighting monsters you yourself do not
become a monster
for when you gaze long into the abyss
the abyss gazes also into you yes
and that's a big part of uh you know the
weight of being a journalist
and doing things like what we're doing
is we cover dirty
nasty painful things to hear about and
to think about
and it can make you angry it can make
you edgy
and and lose focus on how to fix
situations you know
when you're when you're surrounded by
problems all the time yeah so
sorry go ahead go ahead no no continue
okay i was just going to say that
michael tracy just tweeted something
about
an article about journalists who are
freaking out and breaking down
constantly and crying and i was like
that's because they steeped themselves
in the
anti-trump bubble and they were just
stewing in it all this tds
all the time and it like broke their
brains and there's a journalist who
commented her name's like katie or
something and she's like
my brain broke during the trump election
i was like dude
whose fault is that like no one is
making you
dive into this stuff and just swim
around in this cesspool of horrible
thoughts about donald trump all the time
you know yeah so you're right about that
can you imagine the nightmares these
people were having
dude i'd love i'd pay to see one of
their nightmares soon you'll be able to
if this neural network that's right yeah
yeah there's a neural net thing that can
like decode brain images like what
you're seeing and then it translates it
to like a visual
you know approximation i'm just
imagining you know these people all day
every day just they were talking about
after trump got banned they were
celebrating
and a bunch of people like conservatives
were like that's crazy they would
celebrate the censorship of a sitting
president
you got to understand these people
were talking about how they would wake
up in the morning and then their phone
would like they would have a shortcut to
pull up donald trump's twitter
to read what he was saying all they ever
did it's all they ever did because their
companies
wanted them to do it they're like we got
to write about what trump is trump is
doing because trump makes us money
i used to imagine these people having
like you know we talked about the other
day brian stelter
having a nightmare where he's like in an
old rickety house and then he's like
it's like there's like lightning strikes
and then there's trump
you can see him flashing and then he's
like and then when he runs out the back
door it
actually just transports him back into
the front door and he's trapped in this
house and there's trump in the shadows
these people were trapped in a trump
vortex
they became the demon ultimately when
you wanna when you when a problem
you know when all you focus on is the
problem it's you you can't live without
it anymore like that's that becomes part
of your identity
it seems like that's what's happened and
possibly is happening to people right
now
right so so i think it's both
the uh it's it's it's causing
and a cause of the the uh the crisis the
culture war
so the more the crisis escalates in
terms of the fbi raiding someone's home
or antifa setting buildings on fire the
more you will get
say msnbc lying about riots and then in
turn conservatives saying the media is
lying they're fake news
and so it's just a spiral that's
spinning faster and faster and faster
with everyone trapped inside
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you